الشرق الاوسط ينزلق الى حافه صراع اقليمي
اوسع هذا ما كتبه الصحفي جولين برجر في
مقال نشرته صحيفه الجارديان اذ يرى الكاتب
ان هذا الصراع المحتمل قد يضع اسرائيل في
مواجهه مفتوحه مع ايران ويؤدي الى توريط
الولايات المتحده وينقل الكاتب عن خبراء
قولهم ان بنيامين نتنياهو هو الذي يملي
الشروط على على جميع الجبهات لاسباب تخصه
وهو الذي يواجه السقوط من السلطه فيما
التصعيد قد يبقيه في منصبه اما موقع ذا
هيل فنشر مقالا بقلم براد بريس قال فيه ان
الضغط الذي يمارسه الحوثيون على الشحن
البحري في البحر الاحمر يهدد بتكلفه هائله
للاقتصاد العالمي ويستشهد بقول الن ردوف
استاذ السياسه العامه والاقتصاد في جامعه
مشيغن بان السؤال الذي يتردد في اذهان
الناس هو انه لا يمكنك ان تكون في موقف
دفاعي الى الابد لما لذلك من اثار تقلل من
قدرتك على الرد في مجله فورين بوليسي يشير
مقال الى ان عام
2023 كان سيئا للغايه للرئيس جو بايدن في
ملفات السياسه الخارجيه ويضيف ان بايدن
راى بعد هجوم السابع من اكتوبر انه من
الحكمه سياسيا
واستراتيجيا الاستثمار في انتصار اسرائيل
ولكن يبدو ان ذلك جاء على حساب جعل الحرب
اكثر فتكا بالمدنيين الفلسطينيين واكثر
خطوره على المصالح
الامريكيه ويعود مقال نشرته مجله ناشنال
انترست مجددا الى هجوم السابع من اكتوبر
فيرى ان المشكله الرئيسيه في فشل
المخابرات الاسرائيليه في توقع الهجوم لم
تكن في جمع المعلومات بل تمثلت في كيفيه
تحليل تلك المعلومات والتعامل معها وكيفيه
تلقي الاجهزه الامنيه لها ويضيف ان جهاز
المخابرات الاسرائيلي او لجنه تحقيق فقط
بامكانهما تحديد نوع الاصلاحات التي يجب
اجراؤها داخل وكالات الاستخبارات صحيفه
تايمز اوف اسرائيل تخض في مساله التعقيد
الذي يحمله العام الجديد للجامعات
الاسرائيليه اذ ستضطر هذه الجامعات الى
العمل بفصول دراسيه مختصره بعد ان اجلت
بدايه العام الدراسي للجامعات الكبرى عده
مرات بسبب الحرب وادى استدعاء جنود
الاحتياط الى احداث فوضى في النظام
الجامعي نحو 30% من الطلاب يخدمون في قوات
الاحتياط اي حوالي 100000 جندي وفقا لبعض
التقديرات
نظام الصحه العقليه في اسرائيل يواجه
الانهيار مقال بارز في صحيفتها ارتس التي
تنقل عن مصادر مطلعه قولها ان العشرات من
الاطباء النفسيين غادروا مؤخرا الى
بريطانيا مشيره الى ان هذا النزوح ياتي في
وقت يزداد فيه الطلب على خدمات الصحه
العقليه في اسرائيل بسبب حرب
غزه